So, Amy, I hear you want to go to university next year.
Well, I'm not sure I do now.
The fees are really high and I can't afford it.
But anyway, I don't think I should have to pay.
I think university should be free for everybody.
Hmmm.
Well, that's one way of looking at it.
What do you think, Jackie?
I agree with Amy.
Schools are free.
So, why aren't universities?
That's why we pay our taxes, isn't it?
I think all education should be free.
I'm not sure about that.
Everyone knows graduates get better jobs which means they get higher salaries.
So, I think they should pay something for their education.
I'm sorry.
I don't agree.
We didn't have to pay university fees, Matt.
So, why should Amy?
That's true, but we were at university a long time ago.
Yeah, about 50 years ago, wasn't it?
Not quite that long.